[Music]
there's almost no escaping the deluge of
information about the new coronavirus
were both confused and riveted trying to
work out what's real and important and
what's not and Kovac 19 is acting as an
accelerant to conspiracy theories the
digital era we live in is blended with
an analog virus a contagion that lingers
on surfaces waiting for a human host
where it can replicate fear of this
virus is powerful and it's intensified
all kinds of nefarious misinformation
and disinformation that's spreading
online
the result is an explosive force that
could have catastrophic consequences you
cannot make people wear a mask it's not
our laws at all this is just made up by
Bill Gates in them it is 20/20 but at
times it feels like we flash back to
medieval times fear of an invisible
enemy is everywhere and it's making some
people do crazy things before
coronavirus we feared technology would
overtake us undermine us create a world
where we can't tell what's real and
what's fake
president Trump is a total and complete
this deep fake video for example was
made using machine learning moving
forward we need to be more vigilant with
what we trust from the internet that's a
time when we need to rely on trusted
news sources today it's not deep fakes
and sophisticated technology that's
insidious and destabilizing
it's a virus an invisible enemy is swept
across the world so fast and killed so
many even modern hospitals with the best
technology have been overwhelmed
Kovac 19 is moving faster than we can
and is outsmarted our best scientists we
still have no effective weapon against
it that has sown fear and uncertainty
disinformation misinformation going
viral many there are spouting the same
conspiracy theories that we fear in the
United States gaining traction all over
the world there's a lot of psychological
research behind why people find the
simplicity of conspiratorial narratives
appealing Rene direst us
how disinformation spreads online the
idea that someone somewhere is is
maliciously pulling the strings rate so
the world is not out of your control of
someone somewhere is deliberately doing
these things to hurt you then there's a
villain and there's someone who can
direct your anger there's a firehose of
false information memes and hashtags
spewed at us from multiple platforms
shared millions of times and fiction
morphs into what some mistakenly believe
is fact conspiracies that lived online
have now burst out into the real world
online conspiracists have cobbled
together a narrative not grounded in any
fact that accuses powerful people like
Bill Gates of releasing the virus as a
ploy to launch a genocide 'el mass
vaccination campaign for decades gates
has been working on depopulation and
dictatorial control plans on global
politics
this Italian MP even gave a long speech
in Parliament about it
calling Bill Gates a vaccine criminal
the real goal of all of this is total
control the spread of such outlandish
charges may seem silly but the
consequences could be catastrophic if
large portions of the public believe the
intent of gates and public health
experts is nefarious they could be
convinced a corona virus vaccine if one
is discovered will be dangerous
many may refuse it there's evidence
that's already starting a poll in the
u.s. found half of all Americans who
named Fox News as their primary TV news
source believe Bill Gates is plotting to
use a kovin 19 vaccination campaign to
implant microchips in billions of people
to track their movements 44% of voters
who cast ballots for Donald Trump in
2016
believe it too even though neither Fox
nor Trump has promoted that theory and a
Canadian poll for the
of journalism at Carleton University
found nearly half of Canadians believed
at least one of four conspiracy theories
26 percent believed Kovach 19 was
engineered as a bioweapon in a Chinese
lab and released into the general
population and then there's planned emic
exposing their deadly secrets the
minions of Big Pharma waged war dr.
magnets it looks like a slick
documentary and is like gospel for
believers dr. Mike Ovitz is naming names
of those behind the plague of corruption
that places all of human life in danger
the former research scientist who
features in it makes lots of claims not
backed up by evidence including that
wearing a mask is dangerous because it
activates your own virus she was
discredited in 2011 after the journal
Science retracted her paper on a
supposed link between a virus and
chronic fatigue syndrome her fall from
grace was steep she was arrested for a
period of time I think for stealing lab
equipment so this was sort of a
disreputable figure who had really
become kind of a fringe conference
speaker since her paper was retracted
but at this particular point in time she
had a new book out and claimed that her
paper was retracted and other you know
other things had happened to her that
were bad in her career because of
Anthony Fauci who has risen to a
position of prominence in the United
States in our government's response to
Kovac on May 4th planned emic was posted
to Facebook YouTube and Vimeo it spread
unchecked and in just over a week was
shared linked viewed and commented on
more than 8 million times 2 million on
Facebook alone there's a lot of overlap
and conspiratorial communities online
there's a research that shows that if
you believe in one conspiracy theory
you're likely to believe in others so in
the case of planned emic what you
started to see was the queuing on
community picked it up and this is a
conspiratorial community not in the
United States and the Q&M community has
a lot of overlap with what we can call
the kind of more mainstream pro-trump
for a president Trump community the
Mogga community if you will make America
great again
on May 11th YouTube face
book and Vimeo took the video down and
fact checkers have worked to debunk it
but it lives on and keeps being shared
facts aren't as sexy as a conspiracy
when you're sharing something that's
being billed as here is the secret dark
truth of the way of the world that's
much more interesting and compelling and
more likely to get someone to click you
have to create content that's
emotionally resonant hey everybody its
dr. Zubin Damania an actual medical
experts like this Stanford trained
doctor are pushing back with their own
online videos I can't believe I'm
wasting my time doing this but I just
want to stop getting messages about it
because it's really frustrating to think
that people are this fricking stupid
this one debunking plan Demick has been
viewed on youtube more than three
million times you should look at the
credibility of the people who are trying
to convince you that they're right when
they don't have any science to prove it
the UN is working to counter the
conspiracies - we're partnering with a
also a an organization called first
draft news that is closely monitoring
the spreading of misinformation where
it's coming from
and we will prioritize audiences that
are receiving this misinformation and
sharing it as well
it's hoping to mobilize millions of
digital first responders to counter
misinformation claiming 5g cell towers
for spreading the disease has led to
arson attacks in Quebec and around the
world accusations China manufactured the
virus have led to racist insults and
assaults and Bill Gates who five years
ago warned the biggest potential killer
the world faced is not war but a
pandemic and who has spent billions on
life-saving vaccines is now public enemy
number one - conspiracy theorists who
are infecting millions with
misinformation that could be as
dangerous as the virus itself
where does this leave the news consumer
with me is Craig Silverman he's media
editor of BuzzFeed he's an award-winning
author and journalist in one of the
world's leading experts on online
misinformation he started using the term
fake news back in 2014 long before
President Trump weaponized it Craig you
have edited a verification handbook on
media manipulation and in it you make
the point that everything in the digital
world can be gamed and manipulated and
there are a variety of people and
entities with incentives to do it now
that that world has met this real-world
virus what has it led to I feel like
it's a high-water mark in terms of
conspiracy theories misinformation
disinformation just a wide range of you
know very confusing often misleading
information polluting our environment
and we've sort of been leading up to
this point to a certain extent things
have progressively kind of been getting
a little bit worse and worse but you
have a massive global event like a
pandemic which naturally unleashes
conspiracy theories you do that in this
digital environment and this is what
we're experiencing right now a really
high watermark with in terms of this
false and misleading info
what's the onus on social media
platforms who all profit from this junk
to refuse to let it live on their sites
we've seen Twitter fact-check president
Trump's tweets for the first time not
not about coronavirus actually but but
mail-in ballots Facebook's Mark
Zuckerberg though says it's not up to
platforms to be truth police what is
your view well they absolutely have
responsibility here and and they have
acknowledged that responsibility if we
think about how things have changed
since the end of 2016 they were doing
very little to almost nothing to combat
false and dangerous claims on their
platform and now pretty much every major
platform has teams that are dedicated to
reviewing this information Facebook
funds dozens of fact checkers around the
world so it's kind of a strange thing
when Mark Zuckerberg comes out and says
well it's not up to us to be the
arbiters of truth they also talk to the
other side of their mouths saying how
much they've invested in the kind of
efforts to
rid their platform of dangerous and
misleading and false information so when
he says he doesn't want to be doesn't
think they should be truth police you
think that specifically relates to
politicians yes I mean that's the only
sort of interpretation of that comment
that could make it partially true
because they absolutely are helping
arbitrate and decide on the veracity of
content now they've outsourced that to a
certain extent to third party fact
checkers but Facebook has introduced the
program is spending millions and
millions of dollars a year on people who
are whose job description is absolutely
falling into the arbiters of truth level
and Facebook has decided that they don't
want fact checkers fact-checking
political ads and they don't want them
fact-checking political speech and that
in itself is a pretty controversial line
to draw let's talk about the planned
emic it was taken down from a number of
sites but you know it keeps popping up
and it's being shared anyway is there a
way that that can actually be stopped or
is the online ecosystem just too big to
uncover nerville that that it's never
going to happen I think it is a really
good example of perhaps what we can
expect from these platforms at least at
this moment in time and the reality is
that they are too big for them to
actually be able to enforce them
completely and so something like the
planned emic really exploits that
because they know that sure maybe at
some point it gets fact-checking and
starts to be flagged for removal by
facebook itself but they know that they
can get it uploaded by other people the
fact the filmmaker when he released it
he said listen everyone go download the
film because we know it's going to get
removed and we want you to re-upload it
elsewhere so it was really part of their
marketing campaign you could say Craig
there's misinformation which is
spreading wrong information and
disinformation which is deliberately
spreading wrong information designed to
deceive what do we know about who is
doing this when it comes to kovat 19 is
it individuals or state actors or both
we've got a wide range of different
actors with different motivations and so
you talked about misinformation it's an
important distinction I think there are
a lot of very well-meaning people who
are uncertain who are looking for
guidance and help around navigating this
novel
a virus and they will at times
unintentionally spread false and
misleading information so there is a lot
of that happening and then you have this
sort of deliberate bad actors and
frankly they factor in those
well-meaning people they try to design
their disinformation so it appeals to
the beliefs to the biases to the fears
of all of us which might cause us to not
only consume it but to then we share it
and in terms of those bad actors with
the coronavirus we're certainly seeing a
lot of kind of existing alternative
health influencers people who've already
staked out their turth whether it's anti
vaccine activists or people like that
who are really seizing this as their
moment to spread their particular
message there is state involvement in
particular if you look right now there's
a huge propaganda war being waged
between the US and China over the
origins of the virus and blame for it
and there are other state actors
involved as well but I also think we
have to be aware that a lot of people
are thinking that a vaccine is going to
be the moment when all of this starts to
recede but that's actually going to be
the moment when very organized health
information communities like anti
vaccine activists are going to be moving
to the next level of their campaign to
try and create doubt and fear around a
vaccine do you think that conspiracy
theories around that in kovat 19
generally could become as dangerous as
the virus itself I think it actually
could potentially be even worse
in the sense that if you actually create
hesitancy among the population to take a
vaccine that has gone through the proper
procedures and been tested just like you
know so many of the vaccines we all get
as a regular part of our life and
vaccines that have saved hundreds of
millions maybe even billions of lives
around the world
over time and these last few months have
been high-water marks for disinformation
and misinformation I'm very worried
about the groundwork being laid to
really cast out about vaccines and which
could cause potentially more death and
more suffering
still ahead restriction roulette the
best way to solve the economic crisis is
to solve the public health crisis the
truth and consequences of opening up too
soon
plus a mayday for moles I don't think
that they're going to be irrelevant but
I definitely think that they're going to
be changing the new reality for shopping
centers and the people who work there
and up next it was a total win from
chickens to puppies the animals filling
our pandemic void
you